greetings my name is don jones the
current chair of the borlaug scholars
program and i would like to give you an
update from the past year
as many of you know
this program identifies the best of the
best
for undergraduates and graduate students
that attend an institution here in the
united states
and we pair each borlaug scholar
with an napb member who is committed to
their professional development
here's a list of our donors partners and
supporters
without their generous contributions
our program could not have flourished
such that it has
in addition to these institutions we
also have received financial support
from individuals
we'd like to thank each and every one of
them
these are the 13 members who comprise
our committee currently they come from
both the public and the private sectors
as chair i say thank you for their
willingness to serve
we have a monthly zoom call which we
discussed issues and plan for the future
and many of them have also served as
mentors
24 students were selected to be borlaug
scholars in 2021
18 of those are graduate students
they are shown here in alphabetical
order by their last name
and also shown to the right
is the mentor assigned to each
similar to the previous slide
shown here are the six undergraduate
students and their mentor
they too are listed in alphabetical
order by last name
a valuable component of the borlaug
scholars program is the mentoring
between students
and professional plant breeders
on march 2nd a mentoring workshop was
organized and led by the five borlaug
scholars shown on the upper left-hand
side of this slide
as a result 98 participants joined this
zoom call
which involved the four professional
breeders shown on the lower right
and they focused on
covid related discussions
on how plant breeding was affected this
year and other general questions that
were posed by the participants
as a result of this workshop nearly
seventeen thousand dollars was raised
our most recent mentoring workshop
occurred june 29th
this was after we had selected our class
of 2021.
so fortunately they were able to
participate in this workshop
it featured dr curtis cush the winner of
the 1996 world food prize
he discussed the highlights of his
40-year plant breeding career including
the trials in the tribulations that
occur over four decades
53 participated in this zoom call
and he answered questions from the group
for about 25 minutes
here's a screenshot of some of the
participants from our recent event
what we'll now follow are the self-made
one-minute videos from our class of 2021
borlaug scholars
the first 18 are graduate students and
the last six are the undergraduates
these are a treat to watch enjoy and
thank you for listening to this update
on the 2021 warlock scholars program
my name is aj ackerman and i would like
to thank napb for this wonderful
opportunity to be part of the borlaug
scholars program i'm a fourth year phd
candidate at clemson university in the
small grains breeding and genetics
program slated to graduate in may of
2022. early in my career was a co-op out
of monsanto soybean breeding facility
where i got to have my first hands-on
experience with plant breeding while
studying crop science breeding and
biotech as an undergrad i pursued
research in legume plant defense
mechanisms i've extended this work from
model crops to row crops in my
dissertation working with gray mold of
sorghum and fusarium head blight of
wheat
at clemson's pd research center i've
been heavily involved in both the wheat
and sorghum breeding operations and have
had the opportunity to work with a
startup seed company creating exposure
to a smaller side of private industry
i've worked in conventional farming
operations created transgenic organisms
with agback and performed research to
identify impactful traits for organic
programs whether farming operations
primarily conventional gmo organic 20
acres or 20 000 acres farmers still need
the right tools and genetics to
accomplish their jobs in a financially
feasible and environmentally sustainable
manner i want to continue to work in
plant breeding to develop cultivars that
are impactful on the farm to help
growers meet these lofty goals
thank you
hi
i am pawan basnet a third year phd
student at the university of missouri
colombia studying seasonal resistance in
soybean
currently the soybean market is valued
at around 46 billion dollars and is
dominated by a single mode of soybean
system method resistance hence the
identification of novel mode of
resistance and simplification through
breeding approach is of immense
importance my research is focused on
identifying soybeans pneumatic
resistance loci root phenotyping and
diversifying resistance in modern
soybean cultivars besides soybean
breeding i am also interested in
statistics and data analysis i love
traveling exploring new places hiking
and taking pictures my long-term goal is
to make an impactful contribution to
agricultural sector around the globe
through the knowledge gained from my
research and academics either in
industry or at the public building
institutions
thank you
my name is catherine de megona clement
and i'm a phd candidate
working on cotton breeding genetics and
genomics with dr jane deaver
and dr lebo sean
my last name dan may gonna literally
means the son of a great farmer a name
which i got from my grandfather who used
to grow cotton back in nigeria long
before i was born
my research is centered on a new disease
that can kill susceptible cultivars
within one month after planting fusarium
will trace four threatens of plant
cotton production in my research i
utilize the hydroponic system
laboratory and greenhouse protocols
as well as confocal microscopy to
capture the infection process
as well as bioinformatics to assemble
the components of the genome
beyond what i do in graduate school i
have a passion for research and teaching
and i love to give back to my community
by organizing workshops for african
students and researchers in over 50
african countries till date
over 3 600 students have been impacted i
am super excited and proud to be a 2021
bullock scholar
hi everyone my name is nidha godi i'm a
phd candidate at kansas state university
i am working with dr viva bay at usda
central small brand genotyping lab
my graduate research is focused on
map-based learning location flat
resistance scene in v
for this i have screened thousands of
recombinant lines in the in lab and in
greenhouse as well to reduce the qtl
region from many mbs to only 200
kps also i am working on development of
diagnostic markers which can help the
breeders in marker assist selection and
gene pyramiding as well
moreover based on rna sequencing data we
have identified differential express
genes under this region and now i am
working towards learning and
characterization of one of them
this project was not possible without
the guidance and support of my advisor
and other team members especially
documenting
last but not least i am incredibly
honored to be the part of 2021 class of
borlaug scholars i am really thankful to
nap selection gamete for giving me this
opportunity
thank you so much
hi my name is kimberly gibson i am a phd
candidate in horticulture and agronomy
at the university of california davis
with professor paul gapps i study the
biochemical defenses that lima beans use
against their main insect pest lygus
hesperus
some of my methods include field trials
measuring cyanogenic capacity a
genome-wide association study and
measurements with new field-based insect
sensors i also assist with our breeding
program and enjoy teaching undergraduate
students
prior to starting my phd i earned a ba
from stanford university and worked for
several non-profit organizations in san
francisco and yucatan mexico
my family has been farming in california
for several generations i hope to
continue this tradition by pursuing a
career that combines teaching research
and plant breeding i'm honored to have
been selected as a borlaug scholar and
look forward to connecting more with the
wider community of plant breeders
hi i'm amy grow and i'm earning my phd
at uc davis my dissertation work
involves pre-breeding of water use
efficiency traits in tomato
so this involves doing some fine mapping
of water stress tolerant traits in a
wild species of tomato and then doing
some exploratory bioinformatics within
that region
and then finally i'm doing a combining
ability study
using integration lines from two
different wild species
outside of my dissertation work i also
am involved with a collaborative
breeding project called scope here at uc
davis and we're breeding zinnias for
organic management systems
my future goals involve becoming a
commercial plant breeder and continuing
work to help support and create
community for women in science and
agriculture thank you
hi my name is tilani jayakodi i'm a phd
student in the plant-breeding genetics
and biotechnology program at michigan
state university i work in dr dave
douche's potato breeding program where
my research is focused on applications
of genome editing for crop improvement i
also do some bioinformatics work like i
recently sequenced and assembled a new
potato genome using oxford nanopore
sequencing and as an nsf energy impacts
fellow i'm interested in understanding
the relative specificities of the most
popular genome editing reagents when
applied to complex plant genomes i
really enjoy working in small groups so
in the future i see myself either being
a professor at a small university
leading a team at a plant biotechnology
startup or perhaps starting a genome
editing venture of my own someday
i want to thank all the mentors who
helped me get to be to the place that i
am today and i can't wait for the
opportunities to come
howdy my name is fabian leon i use he
him pronouns and i'm a second year
masters student at texas a m university
in college station texas i'm originally
from nicholasville kentucky and i
received my bachelor's in agricultural
biotechnology from the university of
kentucky
at a m i'm a research assistant in the
sorghum breeding program and my projects
involve the evaluation of some of our
programs grain sorghum hybrids and
inbreds
as well as
an analysis of a large historical data
set of multi-environment hybrid testing
across texas geographies i'm excited to
introduce myself as a napb borlaug
scholar and i'm very excited to meet all
of you
and see where my planned breeding path
may cross with yours so thank you it's
very nice to meet you all
hi
my name is eric lutein and i'm a
master's student in the integrated plant
and soil science program at the
university of kentucky
after serving over a decade in the
united states army and traveling to
countries torn by war i've decided to
change my career and focus on increasing
food security
my current research focuses on the
documentation of forage and grain traits
for 367 different tef germplasms
i'm also a trainee in the national
science foundation's graduate research
training ship where my interdisciplinary
team is assessing the use of microalgae
as a potential fertilizer replacement
during the mine line reclamation process
in my off time i love spending time with
my wife and three kids
gardening hiking and coaching soccer
thank you for selecting me as a 2021
napb borlaug scholar
hello everyone my name is lance merrick
and i'm a phd candidate at washington
state university in the winter wheat
breeding and genetics program under dr
aaron carter i've spent my entire life
in agriculture from growing up on a
family farm in south dakota to working
and studying and we breeding over the
last six years over that period of time
i've gained some amazing experiences
that have led me here to washington
state university my current research
focuses on genomic substitution and
genome-wide association studies for
scene leaning emergence and stripe rest
in a large winter wheat breeding program
the goal of research is to increase
genetic gains and selection accuracy
while providing a guideline for the
implementation of genomic suction for
complex quantitative traits in any
breeding program in addition to my
research i'm a freaking outdoorsman i
enjoy hiking and fishing in the summer
and snowboarding in the winter
i like to thank everyone who's helped me
my way and i'm grateful to be chosen as
a 2021 napb scholar
and i look forward to interacting and
meeting my fellow scholars and mentors
thank you
hi my name is chi nguyen
i'm a phd candidate at the university of
florida
under the direction of dr alfred hall
i specialize in biotechnology where i
use molecular biology tools such as
vector cloning and crispr cast 9 to
study mechanism regulating plant
development and responses to the
environment
when i'm not in the lab doing pcr plant
transformation or tissue culture i like
to be outdoor camping or fishing
my research focuses on understanding
micrornas roles and regulating lettuce
seed dormancy and germination under
stressful condition
additionally how these micrornas
influence lettuce organ size will also
be investigated
my goal as a plant breeder is to provide
stress tolerance lettuce to combat the
changing environment as well as high
quality lettuce on everyone's table
thank you napb for this opportunity and
i'm honored to be one of the 2021
warlock scholars
hello
my name is alex obonna with a farming
background and a strong interest in
agriculture
i was motivated to join the cornell
plant breeding phd program
where i work with cassava a tropical
root crop that has become a staple food
for over 800 million people worldwide
my research work in the lab of professor
mueller is focused on the impact of
modern breeding on key trait
architectural evolution through
domestication and its implications for
cassava breeding apples a component of
my research looks at the trait
architecture of the toxic secondary
metabolite compound
present in cassava rule i also
researched in cassava diversity along
with landscape genomics and the
development of transcriptomics resources
for studies of complex trade to assist
cassava improvement effort i am honored
to be a 2021 napb bulla scholar thank
you
[Music]
howdy over the next few decades we'll
have to produce as much food as we have
in the previous
10 000 years combined
[Music]
plant breeding is one of the most
effective tool for adapting to new
circumstances
[Music]
my research as a phd student at texas a
m potato breeding program involves the
utilization of single nucleotide
polymorphic markers
for the molecular characterization
genomic association studies
and genomic selection
[Music]
these studies will be helpful in
increasing the efficiency of potato
breeding
upon graduation i would like to
contribute in the advancement of
agriculture through plant reading
research and teaching
[Music]
hello my name is erin farr and i'm a phd
candidate at rutgers university in new
jersey
my research is focused on breeding and
genetics of big bank adopts the asian
species corniskusa is flowering behind
me here
i love breeding ornamental plants
because it is a beautiful blending of
art and science
for my thesis work i'm conducting a
diversity study of dogwood cultivars and
wild collective plants
i'm also working to improve our native
flowering die with resistance to pottery
mildew through qtl mapping of resistance
genes and crispr knockout of
susceptibility genes
my goal is to work as an ornamental or
vegetable breeder in industry
i am particularly interested in fruiting
for disease resistance
and adapting advanced breeding tools
developing agronomic crops to niche
horticultural crops
in my free time i love hiking painting
gardening and taking care of my
ever-growing houseplant collection
i am honored to be named a burlap
scholar thank you very much for this
opportunity
hello everyone myself current shared
sandhu and i am currently a phd
candidate at washington state university
and then i am working with dr aaron
carter who is leading the winter weight
breeding program
and this summer i am also working as a
phenomic resistor so i've been breeder
intern with bay crop sciences
my thesis title is increasing the
genetic gain in wheat breeding program
using genomic selection phenomics
machine and deep learning algorithm
and in my future career i want to
explore all the techniques or the skills
which i learned during my phd or my
undergrad and want to implement all
those during my future gadgets at a
private breeding company
and during my free time i like to go for
hiking camping and play badminton and
thanks and thanks a lot
napb for giving choosing me as a 2021
warlock scholar thank you
hi everyone i'm swati shrestha a second
year phd student with dr jeffrey meru in
vegetable breeding and genetics lab at
the university of florida my phd
research focuses on development of afe
transmitted virus-resistant squash and
pumpkin cultivars using molecular
breeding approaches aphid transmitted
viruses like zucchini yellow mosaic
virus and papyrin spot virus are the
major ill limiting factor in squash
production worldwide
development of virus resistant cultivars
using traditional breeding relies on
rigorous and resource intensive
phenotypic essays
to overcome this problem i am working on
identification of quantitative traitless
eye and molecular markers associated
with virus resistance that would assist
in phenotypic selection thus
accelerating the disease resistance
breeding
i am really excited to be one of the
nepb borlaug scholar 2021 looking
forward to participating in various
bulldog scholar activities and learning
a lot from them thank you
hi everyone my name is henan souza and
i'm a third year phd student in plant
breeding genetics and genomics at the
university of georgia i'm currently
working in the soybean breeding and
genetics laboratory under the guidance
of dr zhang luli our projects involve
the identification of genes underlying
the control of protein and amino acid
composition in soybeans so we can
improve the nutritional quality we are
also working in the identification of
genes underlying the resistance to
soybean rust so we can breed new
resistant varieties one of my favorite
parts of breeding is going to the field
to evaluate plants and make selections
for our breeding program when i'm not
working my phd projects i enjoy spending
time with my family going to parks
cooking and also watching movies i'm
really excited for being one of the napb
scholars for the class of 2021 and i
look forward to interact with mentors
and the other graduate students this
year in our meeting so i see you soon
hello i'm clayton varta and i'm a phd
candidate in the department of agronomy
and plan genetics at the university of
minnesota my motivation to work with
plain breathing comes from my lifelong
passion for agriculture as i grew up on
a family farm i study soybean breeding
and quantitative genetics under the
guidance of dr aaron lorenz and my
research focused on the implementation
of generic selection in a public soybean
breeding program more specifically in
parental selection for complex traits
through genomic mating and advancements
in an early stage of line testing
during my free time i enjoy playing
volleyball road biking running and
gardening
after graduation i'm interested in
pursuing a career in the industry sector
as a plant breeder or to concentrate on
research and development to optimize
current breeding methods
i'm honored to be a 2021 napb blog
scholar and i would like to thank the
adv log scholars committee and
supporters for this wonderful
opportunity
thank you everyone for listening
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is matthew davis and i am an
undergraduate at the university of
florida where i majored in biology and
minored in entomology
while in florida i had an amazing
opportunity to complete an internship at
walt disney world which led me to the
field of plant breeding
after my return to the university of
florida i had the chance to join the
blueberry breeding and genomics lab
studying under dr patricio munoz here
i've had the opportunity to work with
some amazing scientists
in the future i want to help work toward
addressing problems growers will be
facing due to climate change
in my free time i like to play lacrosse
bake and walk through nature
lastly i want to thank the dr munoz lab
and the blueberry breeding program for
all of the help everybody has given me
and i want to thank the national
association of plant breeders for this
opportunity thank you
hello my name is isabella fiore and i am
currently an undergraduate pursuing a
degree in agronomy from the university
of wisconsin-madison i am about to enter
my fourth and final year of my
undergraduate degree this summer i'm
working at the west madison agricultural
research station for the sweet corn
breeding program there i assist in
producing commercially useful inbred and
hybrid lines growing up i always knew i
wanted to do something in the sciences
that would impact the world in a
positive way it wasn't until i got to
the university of wisconsin-madison that
i found the field of plant breeding and
plant genetics once i found this i was
immediately intrigued
after graduation i intend to go to
graduate school to pursue my phd and i
am excited to eventually do my own
research and also to see where the field
of plant breeding and plant genetics
will go in the future
hi everyone my name is isabelle jen and
i am an undergraduate student at north
carolina state university i am pursuing
a degree in crop and soil science with a
concentration in crop biotechnology and
a double minor in genetics and
horticultural science i am currently
interning under the direction from dr
susana mia lewis with nc state's turf
grass breeding and genetics program in
this program i am involved with
evaluating the use of st augustine grass
cultivar mixes as a possible past
management strategy
although i do not have a background in
agriculture i'm already very passionate
about plant breeding and hope to use
traditional plant brain techniques as
well as
genetic engineering
to contribute to crop advancement and
promote sustainability i just want to
say thank you so much to the napb
for allowing me this opportunity to meet
with peers and mentors about plant
breeding
hello my name is tanner oyen and i am a
senior at the university of wisconsin
where i am pursuing a bachelor's degree
in agronomy as well as a certificate in
business management i found my passion
for agriculture at a young age while
growing up on my family's small dairy
farm in southwest wisconsin although
becoming a first generation college
student was a big change for my family
and i my interest in agriculture was
unwavering this is what drew me to dr
lucia gutierrez's cereals breeding and
quantitative genetics lab at uw
i began working in dr gutierrez's lab in
the fall of my freshman year and just
completed my undergraduate research
project on panicle architecture and its
relationship with seed production
for this project i used rgb imaging to
analyze the digital biomass compactness
length and width of 48 genotypes
replicated over two locations in two
years
we then use matlab software to convert
these images into a data sheet with
these data our lab can identify genomic
regions associated with target traits i
am honored to be a 2021 borlaug scholar
and would like to thank the national
association of plant breeders and
everyone involved for making this happen
hi my name is samantha wagner and i'm an
undergrad studying at the university of
georgia tifton campus
my major is agroscience and
environmental systems with an emphasis
in plant-breeding genetics and genomics
i'm currently working in dr pangchi's
molecular cotton breeding lab and my
primary project is focused on fiber
quality
substantial improvements in fiber
quality can give cotton the means to
compete with synthetic man-made fibers
we have introduced foreign quantitative
trait loci alleles from gastepian barbie
density into upland cotton cassipian
pursuitum by way of marker aided
selection i'm using a transcriptomic and
functional genetic approach
to identify the casual genes from the
inner gress qpls that have shown
positive effects on fiberlink
integration from sister taxa by
marker-aided selection has the potential
of making significant genetic gains and
relatively few breeding cycles if
deployed in cultivar development
it's an honor to have been selected as a
2021 borlaug scholar thank you
again congratulations to the class of
2021.
as you can see the borlaug scholars
program is strong and healthy
thank you for listening